exhumation du corps de rené lui c'est ce
matin ça veut de maintient ses
déclarations et s'insurge contre les
interprétations
record battu pour le dollar si francs 18
et demi le franc toujours très attaquées
pétrole les producteurs s'inquiètent de
la baisse de la consommation mais
cherche à maintenir leurs prix enfin un
cantonales françois mitterrand at il
parlé d'échec pour la gauche en conseil
des ministres mais messieurs bonsoir
toujours la sphère lui c'est à la une de
l'actualité ce soir depuis quelques
jours le nombre des versions de la mort
du directeur de la caisse d'assurance
maladie des bouches du rhône n'a cessé
de grossir et sa veuve en a eu assez
alors que ce matin on inhumé le corps de
son mari à en exhumer le corps de son
mari à fontainebleau pour permettre son
examen un collège d'experts
elle a décidé de tenir une conférence de
presse pour répliquer elle raconte tout
d'abord la nuit tragique
vers 6 heures du matin il m'a demandé
d'aller lui chercher un verre d'eau
alors que j'étais dans la cuisine au rez
de chaussée sur le point de remonter
j'ai entendu un bruit comme une porte
qui claque fortement immédiatement après
ayant fait quelques pas j'ai entendu un
second bruit qui m'a fait penser à une
détonation
sur ce point je précise que je n'ai
jamais dit qu'il s'était passé 5 à 6
secondes entre les deux mûri j'ai
rapidement posé le vert en passant
devant la table du salon et je me suis
précipité dans ma chambre au premier
étage
j'étais à côté du lit dans les secondes
qui suivent ils nous ont pas croire au
spectacle qui s'offrait à moi j'ai pensé
à chercher de l'aide pour mon mari par
réflexe j'ai appelé monsieur paul murat
sully fut monsieur cherche coelho les
deux premiers nous revenons à l'esprit
dans l'affolement
pour moi il s'agissait d'envoyer des
voiliers à mon mari qui avait une
absolue confiance en nous je n'ai pas de
famille à marseille et ma première
réaction était me tourner vers comment
mari l'aurait fait en effet ces deux
hommes ainsi que monsieur marcel chémery
et marc meurin chili ont montré pour
m'amarrer un dévouement total depuis
notre arrivée dans la région
on les a qualifiées de garde du corps
deux gros bras de barbouzes et de
truands et moi marie c'est toujours
élevé
véhémence contre ces ignominies je
regrette les utilisations politique
excessive qui ont été faites autour du
suicide de mon mandat je déplore encore
plus la querelle ignoble qu'on
entretient aujourd'hui sans souci de
l'honneur et du chagrin de ma famille et
de mes enfants je vous demande de
comprendre que je m'en tiendrais la
présente déclaration
et j'en répondrai plus à aucune question
pourquoi est ce que vous faites ces
déclarations aujourd'hui parce qu'au
bout parce que l'ami la mémoire de mon
mari est celle parce que la thèse du
suicide n'est temps à la limite plus
retenu la famille et éclabousser les
proches sont éclaboussés et il faut que
je mette les choses un petit peu au club
même vous n'avez aucun doute vous dire
que non je n'ai aucun doute sur le site
parce que c'était une nuit de folie et
je n'ai aucun doute là dessus
oui mes amis c'est visiblement très ému
qui avait tenu à lire sa déclaration
vous avez pu entendre l'intégralité de
ses propos antennes de midi quant à l'un
des chauffeurs secrétaires de rené
lussier il a précisé qu'à aucun moment
il n'avait touché au corps de son patron
ça y est c'est fait le dollar a crevé le
fameux plafond record des six francs 18
obtenu en août dernier un demi centime
de plus aujourd'hui parallèlement le
franc très attaquées depuis plusieurs
semaines a encore cédé du terrain face à
l'ensemble des monnaies il est
pratiquement à son cours plancher face
heures au deutschemark camaret thierry
louis alors d'abord le dollar vous savez
le dollar influe ti francs 18 le dollar
cher on sait ce que ça veut dire c'est
bon pour nos exportateurs
c'est mauvais pour les importations
notamment pour le pétrole qui est payant
dollars autant dire que si ça continue
on va pas jouir l'on tende l'inoubliable
diminution du super le 4 mars dernier
bond dans l'histoire
qu'est ce qui est plus inquiétant que
d'habitude quand même wibert parce que à
dollars à 6 francs 18 peut-être même à 6
francs 20 demain d'ailleurs pas ce que
c'est il n'est pas garanti que ça soit
fini
ce n'est que 1 des reflets de la
faiblesse du franc autre reflet le franc
suisse à 3 francs 25 et surtout le mark
allemand à 2 francs 60 alors j'ai dit
surtout parce que avec le mark allemand
nous sommes dans le système monétaire
européen le sida le fme a ses règles
ses limites et ses limites qu'on appelle
planchers et plafonds etc nous sommes
assez proches de ses limites pour que
certains se mettent à prononcer parfois
un peu inconsidérément le mode
d'évaluation alors là il faut être très
prudent et voilà alors il faut être très
prudent parce que c'est parfois en
criant au loup qu'on le fait venir les
spéculateurs le savent bien nous ne
sommes pas là pour faire l'enjeu bien
sûr il faut être simplement prudent et
concret alors concrètement évidemment
alors concrètement bien sûr le froid est
attaqué il a attaqué parce que les
milieux monétaires internationaux sont
teintées s'inquiètent du déficit
budgétaire important le connais de la
balance des paiements déficit l'an
pilliard on le sait aussi
et aussi il faut bien le dire du premier
tour des cantonales qui n'a pas été un
succès pour le gouvernement cela dit et
jacques delors leur rappelait hier soir
ici même il ya d'autres indices la liste
des prix qui est très modérée depuis
quatre mois le commerce extérieur qui
s'est améliorée ce mois ci les accords
de régulation des salaires qui avance
bien
voyez les indices qui font ou défont la
conscience dans une monnaie ou dans une
économie sont beaucoup plus partagés que
certains qui ont peut-être intérêts
veulent bien le dire par d'autre part la
banque de france a les moyens de
soutenir le franc et ne s'en prive pas
elle achète du franc beaucoup ces
jours-ci
et puis elle vient en plus de porter son
taux d'intervention et un terme
technique à 17%
en clair cela veut dire que ça va
devenir intéressant d'acheter du franc
et donc de le faire remonter en
conclusion jacques delors ayant les
moyens et la volonté de d'éviter une
bulle une dévaluation ou un réajustement
au sein du s émeut il faudrait vraiment
une accélération formidable de la
spéculation pour l'obliger à changer
d'avis donc ne parlons pas du tout
d'évaluation c'est ça ne serait pas
sérieux
restons calmes et disons simplement le
dollar eh bien cher et mieux asseoir en
semi temps réel mousse mythe se sont
téléphonés longuement on peut gager que
les deux hommes en ont parlé monnaies le
président français a par ailleurs fait
savoir au chancelier ouest-allemand qu'à
son avis les états unis abaisserait
leurs taux d'intérêt au cours de l'été
prochain alors vous lis j'ai tout à
l'heure pierre-marie cette hausse record
du dollar réduit considérablement tous
les espoirs que l'on pouvait placer dans
une baisse du pétrole brut
une baisse qui a pour raison essentielle
le surplus de pétrole en ce moment dans
le monde
les occidentaux ont en effet réduit leur
consommation depuis quelques temps
demain les membres de l'opep vont en
débattre en réunion extraordinaire sur
place
comme il est relié toujours est il
qu'aujourd'hui le choc
ce sont les pays producteurs qui le
subissent le prix du baril de pétrole
sur le marché mondial s'effondre
inquiet de voir cette tendance se
poursuivre les treize ministres du
pétrole de l'opep vont se réunir demain
ici à vienne
le prix officiel du baril est fixé à 34
dollars
on peut s'en procurer un peu partout
pour moins cher
5 $ de moins sur le marché libre de
rotterdam par exemple où les cours sont
en chute libre depuis quelques mois
pourquoi cette chute brutale
parce que dans l'ensemble du monde
occidental
c'est la récession et la consommation a
baissé de plus de 10% depuis deux ans
les économies d'énergie et le retour
progressif à d'autres sources que de
pétrole accentuent les mouvements les
pays producteurs sont donc inquiets pas
tant les plus riches d'entre eux comme
l'arabie séoudite mais les plus peuplés
l'algérie le nigeria l'indonésie ou le
venezuela leur pouvoir d'achat est en
train de reculer brutalement leurs
programmes de développement sont menacés
ainsi que par contrecoup leurs
possibilités de coopération avec les
pays industrialisés comme la france
comment freiner la chute des prix les
pays producteurs proposent envisagent de
réduire leur production mais de combien
et comment se répartiront il entre les
sacrifices réponse peut-être demain ici
à vienne la sphère du fonds la famille
emprisonné à tripoli et dont les libyens
a annoncé hier la libération devrait
arriver dimanche en fin d'après-midi à
paris la mère et le fils aîné semble en
mauvaise santé
ce matin le premier ministre a fait
savoir qu'il était intervenu auprès du
chancelier autrichien 13 qui pour lui
demander d'intercéder en faveur de riz
du pont bleu colère kadhafi et est en
effet à vienne la semaine dernière
pierre mauroy qui par ailleurs se rendra
la semaine prochaine à bonn à son
initiative bonne précisément d'où nous
parlait cette information relativement
surprenante du moins pour un français
désormais un chômeur ne pourra plus
refuser une offre d'emploi même si elle
paraît très valorisante par rapport à
son ancien métier ce que devraient
décider le conseil des ministres la
semaine prochaine en allemand
michel meyer attentes matinale aux
portes des agences pour l'emploi mois
pour trouver un travail hypothétique
pour toucher ses indemnités de chômage
scène de la vie d'un pays qui apprend à
supporter c'est presque deux millions de
chômeurs scène de résignation qui sont
aussi synonymes d'une aggravation de la
facture chômage pour des finances
publiques en déficit vertigineux
on sait depuis hier que le gouvernement
de bonn projette de rendre plus sévères
les critères d'attribution de
l'allocation chômage
ainsi chacun de ces chômeurs risque de
perdre partiellement ou totalement son
indemnité si à compter du 15 avril
il refuse trop souvent un emploi de
moindre qualification
cette nouvelle a provoqué une colère
rentrée chez les chômeurs une levée de
boucliers chez les syndicats mais aussi
fait les patrons qui craignent cas
extrêmes que des licenciés ès lettres
devenu ouvrier ne les laisse tomber à la
première occasion
il n'est pas encore tout à fait sûr que
ces mesures passeront telle quelle la
rampe politique du prochain conseil des
ministres
mais ces attentions font déjà figure de
signal d'austérité sinon de détresse
dans un pays où la crise modifie les
comportements sociaux en contraignant
notamment des accords salariaux ou une
pause
autrement dit une perte de pouvoir
d'achat de 1 % a déjà été acceptée afin
de ne pas aggraver le chômage est de
préserver au maximum la compétitivité de
l'industrie pologne suite de la campagne
d'assainissement de la presse écrite
entre guillemets on va vers la
dissolution de l'union des journalistes
polonais actuellement suspendu
cisjordanie nouvelle montée de la
tension n'ait fait un appel à la grève
générale est décrétée pour trois jours
et ce pour répondre à la dissolution de
l'une des municipalités sur ordre des
autorités israéliennes jean-marc ibrahim
tawil mer au verbe irait en cisjordanie
il a été limogé aujourd'hui par les
autorités israéliennes son conseil
municipal dissous
en violation dit il de la convention de
genève relative à l'administration de
territoires occupés les israéliens ne
peuvent nous imposer ni leur nouvelle
administration civile ni le statut
d'autonomie prévues par les accords de
camp david manifestation donc
aujourd'hui dans plusieurs localités des
territoires occupés par israël
derrière le soutien que ses habitants de
cisjordanie apporte ainsi à l'homme leur
mère l'expression du refus des
palestiniens de coopérer avec le futur
maire d'el bireh demain ce sera un
fonctionnaire israël depuis 67 lui 140
mille palestiniens de cisjordanie vide
sous occupation israélienne
administration militaire que depuis
décembre
israël je remplaçais par une
administration civile pour israël un
premier pas vers le statut d'autonomie
prévues par les accords de paix avec
l'egypte mais une menace politique pour
les mères de cisjordanie
élu en 76 lors des dernières élections
municipales autorisés par israël pour le
gouvernement israélien le boycottage des
mercis jordanien était de nature à léser
les leurs leur joie ils c'est à dire les
intérêts de leurs administrés mais pour
les manifestants des labels dirait le
limogeage de leur mère et selon eux une
nouvelle preuve de la politique
d'animation rampante d'israël en
cisjordanie
les cantonales maintenant avec tout
d'abord cette polémique autour d'un
discrétion parues dans la presse à
l'issue du conseil des ministres d'hier
le président la république at il oui ou
non parler d'échec au premier tour des
cantonales
khlie paroisse pour notre confrère le
matin le président de la république hier
en conseil des ministres à parler
d'échec
à propos du premier tour des élections
cantonales et il a dénoncé certaines
incohérences et hésitations de l'action
gouvernementale
hier pas un mot du secrétaire général de
la présidence pierre bérégovoy au moment
du compte rendu du conseil
et ce matin mise au point très sèche de
l'elysée les délibérations du conseil ne
sont pas publiques les journaux qui font
état de prétendus indiscrétions
n'exprime que leur propre opinion
je dois dire que de notre côté nous
avons mené notre propre enquête
d'où il ressort que le président
mitterrand à bien parler d'échec
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'une
fuite vient du conseil des ministres si
celle ci a nécessité une réplique
abrupte de l'elysée c'est que monsieur
mitterrand a choisi de ne pas intervenir
publiquement entre les deux tours d'une
part pour ne pas gêner pierre mauroy en
première ligne dans la campagne qui
répétait encore ce matin qu'on ne peut
parler d'échec pour la gauche
et puis pour bien montrer que la
fonction présidentielle se situe au
dessus d'une campagne cantonale
enfin parce qu'il est trop tôt pour
tirer un bilan définitif des élections
cantonales le 2e tour n'est pas encore
joué ni l'élection des présidents des
conseils généraux et ce n'est qu'après
sans doute que le chef de l'état fera
connaître son point de vue et les
mesures qu'il compte prendre si
nécessaire
inutile de vous dire qu à trois jours du
second tour chacun appelle les siens à
se mobiliser ce fut le cas aujourd'hui
sur europe 1 pour georges marchais et
bernard pons au cours d'un face à face
pour le socialiste bertrand delanoë il
ne faut pas sous-estimer la droite et le
bureau dilutif du ps a lancé un appel un
vote massif de son côté l'udf bernard
stasi crois qu'il est tout à fait
possible de confirmer dimanche les
résultats encourageants du premier tour
où des joueurs vraiment pas pourquoi les
raisons qui ont provoqué le cuisant
échec de la majorité au premier tour ne
se manifesterait pas aussi au second
tour
d'une parce que les français ont
sanctionné c'est l'usure du pouvoir
c'est une loi de la politique que tout
pouvoir connaît un phénomène d'usure
c'est un phénomène exceptionnel qu'un
pouvoir s'use en quelques mois
sitôt dissiper le brouillard de l'état
de grâce
le gouvernement est apparue à bout de
souffle
incapable de maîtriser la situation
incapable de gouverner le pays
quels que soient les efforts du premier
ministre entre le premier et le second
tour je ne vois pas par quel miracle le
gouvernement retrouverait un second
souffle
est-ce que la deuxième la deuxième
raison c'est le réveil de l'opinion
publique
le réveil extraordinaire de l'opinion
publique française moi je comprends qu'à
sa trempe de français aient pu voter
pour la gauche aux élections parce
qu'ils avaient cru aux promesses
je ne leur jette pas la pierre mais je
considère comme un signe extraordinaire
de maturité du peuple français que tant
de nos concitoyens aient compris en si
peu de temps qu'ils avaient été trompés
faut encore savoir que l'écologiste jean
claude delarue a appelé à voter en
faveur des candidats de la majorité que
le rpr robert poujade à la différence de
son homonyme pierre poujade nu inversion
de photos hier appelle lui à voter pour
l'opposition et que le parti socialiste
rencontrait aujourd'hui la fen très
large convergence de vues at on dit ravi
que force ouvrière
voyez le cnpf accord pour la relance de
négociations salariales
là où elles piétinent un communiqué du
ministre des ptt louis mexandeau la
modification tarifaire ne concerne que
les seules cabine téléphonique à la fin
de l'année pas plus de trois minutes
pour 50 centimes pour les usagers et
bien un projet de taxation à partir de
20 à 30 minutes et l étude pour 85 cents
mille agriculteurs attendu le 23 mars à
paris c'est du moins ce qu'espère
françois guillaume le président de la
fnsea si tel est le cas ce sera en effet
une manifestation historique
un colloque bien intéressant vient de
s'achever en argile et paix centré
autour de la lutte contre la pollution
atmosphérique et regardez bien ces
exemples choisis par gérard delmas
luc doublet il s'agit d'un remarquable
réseau d'analysé de l'atmosphère dans la
région de marseille ou dans certaines
zones comme à gardanne le dioxyde de
soufre fait des ravages cheminée en tous
genres sidérurgie centrales thermiques
pétrochimie et bien sûr roger
d'automobiles l'air que l'on respire
dans le secteur fausse étang de berre un
drôle d'air malgré la brise c'est
pourquoi l'environnement il ya installé
des 76
l'un des réseaux pilotes de surveillance
de la pollution atmosphérique et cet
ingénieur des mines est l'un des hommes
veillant à son fonctionnement
nuit et jour ce réseau fausse berre est
constitué de 23 stations chargé comme
celle-ci d'analyser en permanence
l'atmosphère locales notamment pour les
concentrations de dioxyde de soufre que
nos bronches redoute
mieux je viens d'arriver à la station de
port de bouc
j'ai regardé les appareils pas de
problème aujourd'hui
ces stations automatiques en plusieurs
spécialités y compris de météo et sont
programmés pour transmettre tous les
quarts d'heure les chiffres recueillis
au pc de martigues qui abrite un
ordinateur stockant et traitant toutes
les informations 7000 par 24 heures
gardiens des lieux un opérateur qui en
particulier scrute attentivement les
chiffres transmis et visualiser et
maintient la liaison avec les ingénieurs
techniciens assumant le réseau au sommet
de la colline de notre-dame des marins
la pagode comme on l'appelle à martigues
a coûté avec ses stations presque 6
millions au ministère de l'environnement
et son exploitation est d'un million par
an moitié pour l'environnement - t-il
pour l'association industrielle locale
ce dispositif a pour mission de suivre
les rougets leur dilution ou leur
concentration exemple en hiver quand le
vent oublie de souffler et puis le
système s'occupe également de surveiller
l'évolution des effets des polluants sur
le milieu population faune flore d'arles
à vitrolles et de salon à carry-le-rouet
mais le dispositif ne se contente pas de
regarder il peut intervenir au réseau
nous exploitons
nous avons réussi à mettre à déterminer
des critères qui nous permettent de
déclencher de manière préventive la mise
en alerte des industriels c'est à dire
que dès que ces critères sont recueillis
par l'ordinateur qui exploite les
données mesurées nous déclenchons par
téléphone un ordre d'alert auprès des
industriels
c'est tendre et alerte en quoi
consiste-t-il il consiste pour certains
industriels soit à brûler des
combustibles de meilleure qualité
notamment les combustible à très basse
teneur en soufre qui font que les
émissions sont réduites soit carrément
diminuer le niveau d'activité de manière
significative
de cette manière on arrive à une
diminution de l'ordre de 60% des
émissions polluantes
pendant les périodes dallaire le
dialogue n'est pas réduit aux relations
industrie réseau de surveillance le
public est concerné c'est pour lui que
ce dispositif existe aussi parallèlement
aux informations spécialisées dans la
presse régionale
la population est invitée à exprimer ses
plaintes ou ses inquiétudes même si
c'est une simple nuisance
j'avais le goût
ça sent le chiffon boulot pour moi il
est sûrement
les vins de test
vous saviez un combat qu'est ce que je
peux faire c'est envoyer un technicien
olivier le bon fonctionnement d'un
filtre au charbon
dans le secteur
de boer de vous
lorsque
ce problème là
et on vous tient au courant là
reste l'efficacité de cet outil servant
d'ailleurs aussi à la recherche
et bien c'est une affaire de patience
mais déjà la pollution locale diminue
lentement mais elle diminue
pour l'instant nous n'avons qu'une
quinzaine de ces réseaux mais dans cinq
ans toutes les agglomérations dépassant
100 mille habitants seront dotées de cet
équipement
le journaliste jean-paul gêné restera en
prison il a été condamné cet après midi
à 18 mois de prison dont six avec sursis
pour trafic de drogue en sport tout
d'abord la victoire finalement deux
hilarants mais kelly dans paris-nice se
voyait il a remporté les deux dernières
étapes et a finalement soufflé le
maillot blanc aux français
duclos-lassalle troisième le belge van
den broucke dans la tirreno adriatico
c'est finalement saronni qui l'a emporté
devant knetemann et greg lemond pour
mongole dèche est tout à fait en fin de
peloton avec vous très rapidement parce
qu'on a encore du sport tout à l'heure
avec à 20h30 sur antenne 2 la finale de
la coupe courage de basket la météo
mon cher laurent broomhead oui bien
après le temps instable et les averses
et bien le retour de la pluie dès demain
avant son lot de nouvelles averses un
temps instable pour le week-end et le
retour des éclaircies revoilà donc la
pluie et les parapluies sur la carte de
demain bien beaucoup de nuages d'abord
dans l'ouest le matin qu'ils ont du
cotentin aux pyrénées qui progresseront
dans l'intérieur pour une échappée
finalement pratiquement nulle part du si
ce n'est dans le nord-est du pays
l'extrême nord-est l'est et puis le nord
des alpes est sans doute la corse où
l'otan continuera et puis dans la
journée des éclaircies reviendront un
petit peu de l'autre côté du côté de la
bretagne à l'aquitaine d'aucun temps
pluvieux sur la majeure partie du pays
demain quand même un petit peu de neige
en montagne et retourna car les
températures froides le matin du côté de
0 1 ou 2 degrés dans l'après-midi
semblable à celle d'aujourd'hui mais
comme il n'y aura pas le soleil et bien
ils sentiront ce temps frisquet
nettement plus donc des éclaircies sans
doute pour l'épreuve pour samedi
dimanche enfin l'agenda
12h02 jours 12 heures de nuit à peu de
choses près enfin la fête des joseph et
vous renvoie très vite la balle d'accord
le dernier journal où sera présenté par
hervé claude à 23h15 demain antennes
ministre en direct de montpellier pour
le 20e anniversaire du cessez-le-feu
d'algérie à ce propos le mouvement de
rapatrier leurs cours organise à aix en
provence une journée de deuil demain est
notre invité sera l'ancien président
algérien ahmed ben bella qui sera
l'invité en direct de ce journal de 20
bonsoir à tous à demain